- All right, we're gonna end things
with one last story to
brighten your day, hopefully.
This is what I'm liking.
(instrumental music)
(audience applause)
A Phoenix man is living proof
of the ultimate love
between mother and son,
you're gonna love this
story, and he certainly
deserves the spotlight on
this national Son's day.
His mom has been dealing
with a benign brain tumor for years.
She's okay, but with radiation
she's lost all her hair and
doctors say it won't grow back.
So, he's incredible
and he decided to grow out his own hair
for two years and use it
to make a wig for his mama.
(audience cooing)
It's super sweet.
We have Matt and Melanie
on the line right now watching
on CBS five and three TV.
Hello.
- [Melanie] Hey Kelly.
- [Matt] Hey.
- Oh my gosh, Matt, I wish you were here,
I wanna hug you so hard.
And I mean, just, Well done Melanie.
What a great son you have raised.
What a great young man.
Matt, you say this kind of
started as a joke though, right?
- It kind of did.
I was home between semesters from school
and I go to a school with with
a pretty strict dress code.
And then my parents jokingly said,
Hey your hair's getting a little long.
Maybe it's time for a haircut.
To which I jokingly responded
Maybe I'll just keep growing
it and make a wig for you, mom.
And then it just kind of clicked.
And so, you know, a few
months down the road,
I'm using different products.
My sisters took me to the store
taught me all this stuff about my hair.
(Kelly laughs)
My mom would always
compliment me on my hair
and I would say something along the lines
of coming soon to a head near you.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
So I've learned a lot, but you know, it's,
it was such a small gift to give
to a mother who's given me everything.
So it was a no brainer.
- Melanie, that has to be the
coolest thing, like, you know
to have to go through that in general,
I've had friends that have had cancer and
and that can be a hard
thing to go through.
You know, the loss of hair
the loss of sometimes
femininity like that happens
and that's a beautiful thing that not just
you have that wig to use,
but it, where it came from
the roots of the whole
thing is so incredible.
That's gotta feel pretty special, right?
- Oh, it's absolutely amazing.
When we went to get his
haircut, it was 12 inches long
and as the last of it got snipped off
all of us in the room started crying
that it was just such a momentous gift.
We mailed the hair away
to a company that will create a custom wig
out of the hair that you've donated.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- So it's so great that I have a wig that
fits right and the color's right
because it's our, you know,
my color, my son's color
and that it came out of
compassion and sacrifice and love.
- Oh my gosh.
Wait, you need to write a,
a book on how to raise kids.
Cause Matt, you are outstanding.
That is a cool thing to do.
Thank y'all so much, Matt,
Melanie, for sharing this story.
I'm liking your post right now, alright?
(bell dings)
- [Melanie] Aww.
- And that's not all,
our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of
Frixion, the go to erasable
pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate those creating
fearlessly just like y'all.
So they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
- You're kidding.
- Thank you guys so much.
Y'all have such a blessed evening.
Thank you to all our guests
today, Rosie O'Donnell,
Tyler James Williams,
Pearl, Karen, Kiante,
and Cosee and Raymond
and of course a huge shout
out to LeeAnn Trotter,
Matthew Rodrigues, and all
our friends at NBC Chicago
and Chicago Today.
Y'all have a great day, and if its not,
well, try and change it.
(band playing exit music)